you can move through life at seven times
the rate of other people by simply
changing when you say you're going to
make a decision from end of week to end
of day so think about how that Stacks up
so it's like let's say that there were
four decisions that you needed to make
if the normal person takes a week to
make the decision and then their mind
moves on to the next thing that they
have anxiety for and start making that
decision and decide another week decided
another week decide another week it's a
month to make those four decisions
whereas the Superman takes one decision
day one second decision day two third
decision day three fourth decision day
four they aren't even finished the week
yet and they're where the other person
is at the end of the month how is that
guy so young and he's achieved X Y and Z
well what takes you a month to make a
decision we make it an hour and then the
next hour I make another decision that
takes a year next month and so like
that's how you can go 30 times or 100
times faster than the quote average
person who's overweight has a thousand
dollars in their bank account you know
and it's gonna die at 70